[Music]
howdy my name is Dustin Kirkland I want
to say I genuinely appreciate each and
every one of you for being here
while Kelsey Hightower is giving a
keynote in the in the in Moscone South
so it means quite a bit to me each and
every person who showed up here to
listen to this learn a bit about how
Google is approaching hybrid cloud
computing and maybe see some demos at
the at the end now I do want to
apologize a little bit for this title
for being about as vague as you can
possibly be in the title of a
presentation and that was it's actually
sort of the fault of the fact that we
were releasing gke
on Prem as sort of a big reveal a big
surprise in the keynotes on on Tuesday
morning so this is a title that I really
wanted to have for this presentation and
this is really what we're going to talk
about we're going to talk about how
hybrid cloud solutions actually apply to
enterprise IT and all that is framed now
now that we can talk openly about what
gke google kubernetes engine on prem on
Prem in the data center in the
enterprise actually means so I'm I'm
Dustin Kirkland I joined Google about
three months ago as a product manager on
the kubernetes team I've been around
kubernetes an open sewer I've been
around kubernetes for a couple of years
now have been around open source for
almost 20 years having started at IBM
working with big enterprises I spent the
last 10 years in my career working on
Ubuntu developing and building abun - as
a cloud operating system and have really
shifted gears at this point to to use to
bring kubernetes technology into the
into the enterprise and doing that with
with Google Cloud so the obligatory safe
harbor slide I think this goes without
saying but this is Google next the
conference is literally called next this
is what we're doing next this is a peek
where our roadmaps are going for our
products where where our solutions are
headed for customers I've spent every
every minute of this week not in a
presentation with with customers and
that's been dozens of customers who have
who have teamed up with me and my fellow
product managers to help drive those
products in the direction that
enterprises need and actually want so
what you're going to see here is a look
at where we're taking GKN prim and safe
Harper guarantees about how things might
change and evolve evolve over time this
is a good slaw to take a picture of
definitely all right
so point number one bringing Google
cloud technology on prem is an absolute
game changer for IT this was the initial
premise for this presentation not
premises which is the physical place
where we're going to bring the stuff but
this is the premise this is on which
we're basing this entire approach and I
had to go and add this slide just this
morning a tech journalist Ben keeps who
have long enjoyed his takes on
technology he tweeted this out just
saying that you know he sees this
particular announcement gka on prem as
perhaps the the biggest announcement
this week and this made me very proud in
part because of how much I respect Ben's
Ben's insights into the industry but
just how simply an eloquently he said
this and the fact that that's exactly
the point that I hope to make one of the
points I hope to make here so GK on
on-prem first of all that hopefully the
name describes it all it's Google's
kubernetes engine we've taken kubernetes
open source kubernetes we've built it in
the opinionated way that we Google want
to run kubernetes and host that for our
customers for our users of Google Cloud
who want a curated hosted experience now
that's not the only way you can use and
run kubernetes there's lots of ways you
can use in run kubernetes there's over a
hundred distributions of kubernetes
can take it and build it yourself I have
it's fun but sometimes you want someone
else to worry about managing that
running that running that data center
that hardware those VMs securing the
entire stack providing the updates the
security the maintenance overtime and
that's what gke is Google's hosted
kubernetes engine and of course company
our competitors have their own offerings
what we're doing here is we're literally
literally taking the same bits the exact
same bits that we use and we run inside
of Google's data centers to provide gke
Google's hosted version but we're going
to do that on Prem in a data center
wherever it is that you want to run gke
the asterisk here is part of the the
safe harbor I'm required to tell you
this is now an early access program and
I have a URL for you at the very end
where you can go and sign up to to have
early access to this technology and
these features this extension of google
cloud itself now what is it
fundamentally this is I think it all in
one slide this says just about at all
it's a single pane of glass that gives
you real visibility administrative
visibility monitoring and logging
visibility across workloads running in
Google Cloud GCP Google cloud platform
as well as unpresentable to orchestrate
and manage those workloads those
containers just the same whether it's on
Prem or in the cloud the operating model
is consistent and I think that's
important it's really important there's
a lot of variability in the way that
that kubernetes is used and there are
some ways that that that are maybe
attractive from one perspective or
another what we've what we've done we
think is we've put a lot of effort into
the UI in the ux the user experience for
how container orchestration should look
inside of google cloud and now that's
available on prem as well
but the operations are is really at the
heart of it right
Google's site reliability engineers sres
are absolutely world-class when it comes
to taking care of your technology inside
of our data centers but now we're using
those same tools to install and
configure and automate and update
maintain and deploy that on Prem the
same way we do that in Google Cloud the
environments are consistent and
consistency is super important when
you're programming against api's knowing
that those api's are going to be the
same in one place as well as another
that those operating system images are
available both hosted in the cloud and
on-premise acure and that the same
components are available in one place
and another now the the Google Cloud is
quite rich in terms of how many
different features and plugins there are
and how how tightly those are coupled
and over time we're working to bring as
many of those as possible on Prem as
well
we're starting with kubernetes itself
the core orchestration of containers
itself and then you can sort of imagine
the other things that might make sense
to to run alongside that inside of your
data center but we go beyond that so
that there's automated operations but
there's also management and help with
that and so we're offering full and
partially managed kubernetes where the
the real magic is is in the automation
in the intelligence that we've built
over time as to what it takes to keep a
node up and healthy running predictive
when that node is not going to be
healthy at some point in the future so
that we can take corrective action one
of the most beautiful things about
kubernetes from a technology standpoint
is that it was designed with this in
mind right
I've been around Linux and open source
software for a couple of decades and the
number of projects that add the sort of
health monitoring after the fact that's
almost
the de facto standard kubernetes is sort
of the exception in that it was built so
that updates and upgrades could happen
with zero downtime we it's it's it's
quite an elegant concept but it's really
simple at its core whenever we want to
upgrade a node we take that node out of
the pool of eligible nodes for workloads
to be scheduled to it so that no new
workloads show up on that node we then
drain that node of those those workloads
move them elsewhere then we can take
that node offline do an upgrade and in
some cases we just we kill the node and
we start a new node all of that's built
directly into kubernetes itself and and
has been from from day one so from
cluster health auto repair these are
services that Google provides to gke and
we're bringing to gke on-prem as well
okay so that's the first section of the
talk as as the biggest announcement I
think here this week GPA on Prem is an
absolute game changer for enterprise IT
the second section of this talk is
really the customer empathy session
section of the talk here I think I think
we've done a lot of work in research to
understand why hybrid cloud actually is
important to the enterprise CIO to the
IT department to the director of a data
center who has real needs real needs to
run some workloads on Prem and just
can't run those in the cloud and so I've
got roughly 10 use cases use cases that
we've we've learned we've studied for
why and when and where hybrid cloud
actually makes sense and those ten
separate use cases sort of fit into one
of these six buckets I know I said 10
this is six we have six buckets and each
of the next ten sort of apply so for
these next 10 slides I'd like just a
little bit of audience participation I'm
going to show 10 different places where
we think hybrid cloud actually matters
and makes sense and is a requirement in
some cases
so if one any one of these next ten
slides and you can vote multiple times
it actually sings to you speaks to your
heart just give me a thumbs up and that
will that will help us especially some
of the other product managers who are
here in the audience help us just
understand the impact that some of these
some of these these approaches actually
have in your businesses all right so
here we go so let's just try this thumbs
up all right
all right that's all we have to do
simple right you don't have to stand up
you enough to say anything just a simple
thumbs up okay so one example of a
hybrid environment that I've got
personal experience with is working in
the banking and FinTech industry where
some workloads have to run next to a
stock exchange period it just laws of
physics the wiring the copper between
the fiber between the data center and
the stock exchange the length of that
matters and a matter of a few few
hundred meters makes a difference from a
latency perspective their workload some
workloads that need these nano second
latencies this is very much event-driven
processing something happens and then
something else needs to needs to happen
it needs to happen very close to where
that that first that first event
happened and it's real money there's
real money involved when those Layton
sees go beyond a certain a certain
tolerance there are in many cases very
specialized hardware involved hardware
that's not available in in the public
cloud some of this hardware is custom
designed Asics or a very particular
field programmable Hardware and highly
proprietary algorithms that for better
or worse for one reason or another just
will not move outside of an on-prem
environment okay now all that said there
are complements to that unfree more
cloade that make a lot of sense in in a
google cloud there are jobs that run
nightly as a batch job in many cases
we're talking about models that can be
trained in our trained and improve and
criminally approve every single night
but harness the the public cloud to do
so those are not time since they've just
as long as it takes
place once a night or once a week or
once a month and integrates all of all
of the transactions that have happened
in the previous day or week or month and
that and that model improves over time
and that can be run at a much lower
expense or perhaps more efficiently in
in the public cloud and in Google cloud
in many cases those algorithms are
developed and tested in the public cloud
but they end up running locally and next
to the stock exchange or stock exchanges
and then from an event-driven standpoint
cloud pub/sub is an excellent Google
technology that allows you to create
publications and subscriptions and take
certain actions when this happens all
right in the into anyone in the room
does this one a few thumbs up okay good
so let's go from the the suits and
pinstripes to maybe what these what
these stock brokers are doing at night
which is playing a Counter Strike right
on there at home at night so multiplayer
online gaming increasingly so and I've
worked with a number of of companies
that deal with massive multiplayer
online gaming increasingly so those
online the online games where you're
interfacing with another player your
avatar that you see on your phone or on
your screen is actually a container
running somewhere in the world and the
people that you're interacting with that
you're you're collaborating with to
build a city or you're shooting up
because you know they're the bad guys
and you're the good guys they're
actually a container running ideally in
the same data center and perhaps even on
the same physical machine and it ends up
being a container shooting at another
container where those things are all
happening inside of a data center and
it's happening like this and all your
singing ultimately on your screen is a
physical rendering of what happens and
that's becoming more and more the
standard as we play games on little
bitty devices like this that have very
miniscule CPU and GPU to handle all that
processing and you're basically watching
a youtube video of yourself playing a
game this is what it what it ends up
being and all of that happens inside of
a data center now sometimes those happen
in
the clouds and and Google's got a an
excellent set of customers running
gaming gaming hosts inside of Google
cloud but in some cases those require on
Prem resources I've seen a few that need
bare metal no virtualization bare metal
that tends to be tends to be a
requirement when latencies are extremely
low and there is no concern for
multi-tenancy right and ultimately these
are apps that are containerized and
running inside of what amounts to a
kubernetes or some sort of container
scheduling algorithm now what happens in
the in the public law what happens in in
Google cloud well often there's a global
control plane there's consolidated
identity and billing that's the first
point of entry to to the to the either
the web interface or the app interface
and then traffic gets directed to
separate geo-located perhaps
environments okay so from Stock Exchange
to multiplayer online gaming any does
anyone have a business need around this
or is this just like fun okay cool bit
of both great so a third case is the
telco base station okay I've spent a lot
of time working with telco and I've had
the privilege to actually visit a couple
of telco base stations has anyone ever
been inside of a telco base station
underneath the cell tower yeah all right
good
you can tell us what it's like but the
ones that I've seen especially the new
ones that are being built to handle 5g
connectivity involve multiple racks of
servers typically they're caged off in
such a way that Sprint has one cage and
Verizon has another cage and AT&T has a
has a third cage and inside of each of
those cages there's a rack of hardware
and in a small cell tower it's a half
rack and some of the big ones it's
multiple racks of real physical servers
cranking the data that's going to your
phone and from your phone in some cases
there and these are local applications
that run inside of each cell tower there
are content distribution networks
caching of data you know we're
watching more videos on our phones and I
certainly enjoy watching the World Cup I
did a lot of that from my phone much of
that data was being cached at the at the
local cell tower when you're watching
that over a 4G connection for instance
and these are largely third-party
applications not developed by the telco
applications that they buy to handle the
routing of SMS messages and the playing
of content and simple stuff like making
phone calls right and there is a massive
amount of computing power necessary to
do that and it has to be done at the
cell tower it has to happen at the cell
tower and what's really interesting
about this is that this is a case where
there's typically lots of computing
power and a huge pipe of data flowing
from that cell tower back to the back to
the data center or to the to the cloud
and so this is a this is definitely a
case where we've seen the the vendors in
this space wanting kubernetes or
something like kubernetes to handle the
orchestration of those many and varied
apps apps that are being developed and
released and patched and updated at
cycles that are asynchronous with the
rest of the development cycles and
certainly with one another right you've
got vendors in that cell tower from lots
of different lots of different companies
now what happens inside of a Google
cloud could be the control plane again
certainly the handling of the remote
management and updates when you've got
tens of thousands of these cell towers
rolling out updates requires a very
centralized management control plane and
then consolidating the logging and
analytics being able to audit those
search those detect failures train
models on when some hardware is about to
fail and you have to roll a truck out
there to replace some hardware all right
so tell Co industry anyone has anyone
seen this yeah exactly this need for
hybrid computing so video transcoding
I'm sort of these are in no particular
order but video transcoding is a little
bit related to that multiplayer online
gaming situation and that that's in the
median energy
industry but we've seen a ton of video
transcoding algorithms being implemented
on top of kubernetes it's a perfect
platform for dividing up massive jobs of
transcoding typically what happens when
some video needs to be produced and
delivered to all of our devices you know
we've got many and varied devices just
here in this room from our phones to our
laptops to iPads or our tablets each of
those has a different has a different
resolution and in many cases the video
is transcoded for literally every
different every different resolution
that it might need to be transmitted to
just so that it can be done as
efficiently and and optimized as well as
possible for your particular environment
now there's the the fun and exciting
things like like movies in 3d and 4k and
working with some of the the interesting
video production houses in in Hollywood
and then there's the really boring stuff
which is actually most of the video in
the world and it's the security cameras
that are around every public place every
shopping mall hotel much of that video
transcoding takes place first on prim
and then some of it is archived to the
cloud samples of its archive to the
cloud or there's cold storage being
stored in the cloud but it often takes a
local transcoding job to handle the
massive amount of data so again this is
just laws of physics the data can't
transfer fast enough to the public cloud
some of that needs to be done local and
on print but once it gets to Google
Cloud it's some of the vision ml api's
that are that are being developed inside
of Google cloud are absolutely amazing
if you've used Google photos I've been
blown away by going through 20 years of
photos that I've uploaded to Google
photos and I was looking for looking for
this picture of a of a watermelon that
in college we we blew up because it's
fun to blow up things when you're you're
in in college in Texas and so we blew up
a watermelon and we were laughing about
this me and some buddies at our union
some time ago
and I just wondered can I find that
picture and sure enough I typed in
watermelon I found about two dozen
watermelon pictures over the years and
it's it was amazing one was like a dress
my daughter was wearing that's like
little watermelon cartoons on it and
Google photos figured out that was a
watermelon and sure enough we found the
watermelon we blew up and I was a I was
I was a fun time but the fact that once
you get that data into the cloud and you
can run those algorithms video
transcoding is extremely powerful when
coupling on-prem with with public cloud
so video transcoding has anyone had
video transcoding jobs that they've
needed to run on prem yeah so retail I
think I've met more retail customers
this this week than maybe ever in my
career and I've dealt with some some big
retailers but this particular week has
been an extremely enlightening and
interesting set of conversations around
retail computing and the retail industry
as much as you know we as much as we buy
things online and they get delivered to
our house they're still there still is
this massive massive brick-and-mortar
retail industry and it's it's not going
anywhere
and in fact that retail industry is
investing heavily in clusters of servers
and computers there on-prem inside of a
shopping center almost every shopping
center whether it be a mall or a strip
mall or just a set of stores shares a
little bit of compute typically provide
it by the the landlord or the owner of
that retail who usually owns a few of
those and has a very similar software
and hardware setup spread across those
different things and whether it's a
giant big-box retailer or it's a it's
it's a small chain of stores there's
consistency in the hardware and software
that gets that gets rolled out so
there's typically whether you realize it
or not there's typically a cluster of
servers in the back of the shopping
center that handles a bunch of local
apps and we've already talked about
video transcoding but there's you know
there's about a dozen cameras per
what was the number for per thousand
square feet to cover that much area and
there's a reel of tape and it's not Dave
a reel of hard drives recording that
record storing those recordings locally
so that when there is a problem and they
need to give off that data to local law
enforcement they they can do so and
that's all local that hasn't been
transferred and then there's cold
storage that happens in the cloud and an
archive and then there's inventory
management some building automation the
HVAC or or the lighting being able to
handle it control that in some cases
there's there are city regulations that
some of that needs to happen and be able
to happen locally in the case of an
emergency and can't has to have a
fallback plan when it can't connect to
an internet connected service and of
course the point-of-sale system the
heart of every business is a
point-of-sale system there are typically
your credit card transactions are logged
locally their batch sent to the payment
processor but there's a backup kept for
some amount of time just in case
something happens you know you've you've
probably seen that credit card
transaction that didn't show up for an a
few weeks or a month or two but then
showed back up and it was because
someone had to go back and and check an
audit log found something missing and
was able to pull that off of a second
copy or a local copy perhaps now all
that said Google Cloud offers a real
compliment to this retail this retail
cluster whether that's a global web
presence being able to direct that
traffic geographically to the to the
best possible location or server
certainly cloud storage for those those
the video in those transactions the auto
ml and the insights the buying patterns
they use your the user buying patterns
there's been a number of good sessions
this week about the about the retail
industry so retail sorry anyone here
from from retailer sorry let me not ask
anyone here from retail this is this use
case speak to some of your needs yeah
smart buildings and smart cities you
know one of the one of the biggest
places I think we we will see in this
next in this next deck
at a real market improvement in our life
is through automation safety
improvements technology driven
improvements in the way we live and
interact with one another and that can
be in both rural environments as well as
highly dense environments like this and
this really starts with smart buildings
and smart cities so just about
everything that I said about the retail
shopping center that has a rack of
servers doing things that have to be
done locally as well as most of what I
said about a telco base station with
some applications that need to run
locally if you go to any of these
high-rise modern skyscrapers there's a
rack of servers in the basement doing
building automation and and certain
transactions that have to happen within
that building itself and I've said
security I don't know how many times now
but it ends up being quite a bit of
security feeds HVAC and just running the
operations of the building itself now
the smart part of smart buildings and
smart cities is using AI and ml to train
models and improve the performance and
the operation of some of those some of
those aspects that that we come to
depend on from a technology and
infrastructure perspective training
those in the cloud and sending the
models the trained models back down to
the clusters to implement is is a really
an interesting handshake so smart
building smart cities this one might be
a little bit on the fringe but has does
anyone have any experience in this space
and see hybrid computing yeah that's
that's good so data provenance is one
that you know I think we've all
experienced this year anyone who's had
anything to do with gdpr and then prior
to GDP are any of the other personal
privacy protection either legislation or
regulations and in some cases just our
own processes that we have in the
enterprise around where data can be how
long it can live how it needs to be
encrypted and treated and in some cases
there are simply legal obligations there
are compliance requirements around where
that data lives and
and no matter how secure and encrypted
at all levels Google Cloud actually is
theirs there are some processes that
just require some data to be stored
locally and on Prem and we can we will
continue to improve the security and the
compliances and the list of of
compliances it's actually quite an
impressive list at this link here of
compliance audits that Google Cloud has
past will continue drilling that but
there's some data that for one reason or
another another needs to live somewhere
else and perhaps it's inside of a
country in some cases it may just be for
a liability limitation there's an
insurance policy that a company might
have where their insurance policy is
different depending on where their data
is is store though that's what their
their auditors have told them now that
said inside of Google Cloud we do have a
really rich security feature set your
data is encrypted at every single level
all the way down the stack of virtual
machines are booting in in trusted boot
environments and then there are
extremely fine-grain identity and access
controls our back access controls around
that you have control of as to in your
organization who can access given
buckets of data so from that perspective
this is a case where you know date some
data lives in some places and some data
is replicated elsewhere some data is
encrypted with a set of keys that stores
the data but it's protected unless those
keys are available so from a data
provenance provenance perspective this
is a this is another driver for some
hybrid use cases does this resonate with
with anyone Wow
it's a popular that's a popular one for
sure so then we go toward lift and shift
lift and shift being maybe some
traditional workloads that have long
lived in an enterprise data center but
for one reason other you'd like to move
them to the cloud possibly even in the
other direction in that you know it can
really go either way I've seen and I've
worked with a cup
of large customers moving virtual
machines to the cloud Google acquired a
company called Bella strata and I'm the
product manager associated with with
Bella strata as we're as we're working
to integrate Vella strata into in a bit
tighter into Google cloud but fellow
strata has some technology that will
take a VMware virtual machine image and
livestream that image to Google compute
engine without downtime and actually
move that VMware image into a VM in the
in the public cloud in Google's cloud
and it's really quite impressive it's
it's a great demo and it's something
that we've helped organizations move
thousands of legacy applications running
in VMware inside of their data center
into a hosted cloud environment I've
certainly been in a data center with old
dusty machines that no one's quite sure
how it's still working because you know
the fan makes a noise about 60 times a
second and at any point it could fall
over and boy that's that's just going to
be a bad day and so moving some of those
workloads into the cloud tends to be a
priority and in some cases this is what
people really mean when they mean hybrid
cloud being able to just move a good old
VM from one place to another and we're
seeing more and more of that with
kubernetes as these these applications
are lifted and shifted they're actually
moved and improved they're modernized as
they as they actually move into a cloud
and and there are some advantage
advantages to be had by moving them into
a container not having to worry about
kernel updates for instance and that you
know the real point is that most legacy
software actually predates the cloud
that's sort of the definition of legacy
at this juncture in time anyway and and
from that perspective some of those
workloads can't or won't or just are not
well suited to moving to the to the
Google cloud for one reason or another
and that that might that might be an
impetus for in some cases using both
on-prem for some workloads and public
law for other workload
so from a lift and shift perspective is
this an initiative with within any one's
organization yeah I we see that we see
that quite a bit so this is a fun one
and I actually know a really interesting
young man he's interned me in turn for
me a couple of different times but in
his last internship he had this really
interesting job which was to create a
calculator that would determine for a
given job they he was working for a
company that did a lot of large
large-scale AI ml jobs jobs that cost
tens of thousands of dollars to run just
one time just running this job one time
it was tens of thousands of dollars and
his job as an intern was to figure out
the cheapest way to run that job meaning
which which cloud whether they use GPUs
or TP use how big the instances should
be and the that tool will save this this
company maybe twenty percent maybe two
three thousand dollars for each job if
it could find the the cheapest right way
to to run it and in some cases now their
organization was entirely public cloud
but I've seen this model actually work
where sometimes it makes more sense to
simply run a job on Prem for one reason
or another and other cases it makes more
economic sense to run that in in Google
Cloud for instance and so you know you
get this this sort of decision tree of
when to do which and it's actually quite
simple wherever it's cheaper wherever
it's less and less expensive or costs
less and I call that the economic
arbitrage it's like we're gonna
arbitrage this job and and run it where
it's most efficient
does anyone have to make this decision
or has has an algorithm to make this
decision for them yeah it's it's a real
driver for business and you know it
shows it can show you where where your
efficiencies are available so this is
kind of the classic dev test see I CD
into prod I've worked with organizations
that do that all of their development in
the public cloud but then run their
their production servers
on-prem and i've seen exactly the
opposite we do all of our development on
our laptops on our Macs on our our Linux
machines but then we run and host in in
host our production servers in in the
cloud and so you know what we're not
prescriptive about that from from this
perspective I'm certainly not
prescriptive about it whatever makes
sense bringing gke on Prem for instance
gives you the ability to do either you
can use the on Prem cluster for your dev
and test and and gke for for production
I certainly think that makes a lot of
sense but you could just as easily do it
in the other direction and send your
load balancers your traffic elsewhere
and so I think this is kind of one of
the classic hybrid models using a bit of
public cloud a bit of on Prem I'm
guessing a few people have experience
with with doing this for sure yeah and
then finally the last one is and I've
seen this now from a number of a number
of banks and some regulated industries
that are deemed just too big to fail
that they're actually spreading
workloads across multiple multiple
clouds we're running in Google Cloud is
great and then having another plan is
actually regulated required by by
industry regulations just in case and so
there's a lot of reasons that could go
here but I think this is a different
type of of hybrid cloud this one isn't
necessarily on Prem 2 to Google Cloud it
certainly can be but it could be from
other clouds to Google cloud so there's
this one this one hit home with anyone
yeah okay so that's our 10 use cases
I've studied each of these and you know
we've we've put together from a product
and strategy team put together quite a
bit of critical quite a number of
critical user journeys through each of
these and we are working from a hybrid
cloud computing standpoint with these in
mind so maybe at the end I'll ask if
there's I'll just ask right now I've got
just a couple of minutes
is there any major use case that I've
missed here or do these pretty much
cover
yes Research Institute
GPU hardware yep so that's that's a
that's a great example they've got a lot
of hardware that they've invested in GPU
Hardware in a Research Institute and
it's sort of there and you want to use
it because it's because it's there but
you want to take advantage of newer GPUs
perhaps newer hardware and the burst
ability of a public cloud good thank you
okay so the third point to make here is
that we really do have a world-class
cloud I hope that you've you've enjoyed
your week here I think we're starting to
wrap up I found this an amazing
three-day exhibition of just the the
innovation and inspiration of how how
much work my colleagues my engineers put
into what they do every day
I've learned about corners of Google
that I didn't didn't know existed some
of the announcements were as new to me
as as to you here hopefully you've been
educated a little bit but you know I
think hopefully the the previous section
shows you that we we really know we're
really come to understand we're coming
to understand what hybrid cloud is by
you know classifying this understanding
these use cases having this sort of
feedback but I think that the inverse is
actually true as well I think hybrid
actually knows knows Google and actually
uses Google in a lot of different ways
you know if we start with like the last
10 to 15 years of Google products
Enterprise products it goes from G sweet
from using from using Google Docs and
maybe hangouts or mail calendaring
inside of the enterprise while the
enterprise still has its own IT
data center this is a piece of IT that
used to be in in servers stored locally
storage maybe for documents who
remembers emailing documents around boy
what a miserable time it was to work in
this industry when everybody would get a
copy their own copy of a doc and I mean
how did you do collaborative editing I
couldn't live without that today it's
like going back to a typewriter that the
leaf is almost the same but now that's
all stored essentially in a public
in Google's public cloud but secured and
cordoned off to Android Enterprise you
know being able to use those same apps
securely on a phone managed by an IT
security organization your own IT
security organization who does that
through Google's technology and then
it's it's really it's really coming to
Google cloud as well the enterprise
using leveraging Google Google cloud and
I'm here to really just talk about
kubernetes engine but there's so much of
so many of these products are actually
quite applicable to the enterprise and
bridge that bridge that gap and that's
this that's the point here we're working
hard to bridge the gap between your data
center and Google's services and I say
services and not servers because we
really are looking at this from a
services perspective we produce services
that you can consume ap is that you can
talk to applications but those
applications end up being Google Google
services in fact and gke on Prem is
super special here this is really the
first time we're bringing Google
software into the enterprise data center
that's the the only other example we can
we can really think of here where
Google's done something similar was the
is the Search Appliance which was
actually a physical Hardware appliance
that you installed in your rack and
indexed your data documents websites on
your internal intranet that was a
physical appliance this is this is
different this is software Google
software that runs inside of your
enterprise data center and that's a game
change that's really different I can't
understate how important that change
that change actually is and so wrapping
this all up and bringing it together I
think if you were going to take a
picture of one slide this is the one
that I think says it all here if you
really treat Google cloud as an
extension of your own data center just
imagine how powerful your data center
ends up being it's sort of the analogy
of you know your your phone that has
to the Internet and suddenly this tiny
little thing is as has access to
basically all of the information that
has ever been created in the history of
mankind and this is your interface to it
if your data center itself is connected
to Google Cloud and using Google Cloud
technologies just imagine how powerful
that that data center that data center
becomes I'm actually gonna skip this and
go straight to a demo I think you guys
would rather see a demo than an
architecture slide well very briefly
this is the sort of architecture I've
I've whitewashed all the the customer
names and the customer code names off of
this but this is essentially a retail a
retail use case a retail customer who's
using a blend of Google cloud platform
and their own online enterprise data
center as well as some technology slated
to run on Prem in in the store on on
site that's just one architecture for
one of those ten use cases that that I
described but Google's customer
engineering team and and solutions
architects can create this sort of a
design by interacting with the the right
person in your IT organization very
smoothly okay so let's see a demo so
this was that single pane of glass which
was a snapshot of a of a web page you
want to see this in action yeah okay
I can't do demos with a jacket on it's
just it's not right it's absolutely not
right all right so
I'm gonna get rid of that all right this
is my my Google Cloud console I'll blow
that up a little bit and I've got a
cluster running on the East Coast
somewhere and that's my one cluster in
fact this is the cluster this is half of
the cluster that was used in Tuesday
morning's keynote the one where we had
the the big reveal that there's actually
this is being served on stage half of
that cluster was running in Google Cloud
the other half was running there on
stage now what I want to do at this
point is register an external cluster
and for this cluster I'm gonna name this
cluster cluster Palace and unfortunately
I was not able to get the the rack of
Hardware up here but I do happen to have
kubernetes running on my Linux laptop
right here in Palace gold room so I've
registering this external cluster I'm
going to download this manifest and I'm
now on my local cluster and I can do a
cube Kittel get all and you can see I've
got a little kubernetes up and running
here on my on my laptop now if I simply
cube Kittel apply to the namespace gke
connect the yellow file that I just
downloaded that will set some key value
pairs and I'm gonna see this is waiting
for that connection to happen and while
that's happening actually let's go back
and do something else let's register
another cluster and this is going to be
a bare-metal cluster that's running in
Texas so I'm going to download that one
and I'm going to come over to my
bare-metal cluster in Texas and I'm
gonna cube Kittel apply let me just make
sure this is up
okay and I'm gonna wait for that one to
come up and actually I need to do one
more little thing I need to enable a
couple of services
and we're gonna get to I'm going to need
to apply a my secrets I'm going to do
that there and that there and then we're
going to kick that off one more time
all right and what we should see in just
a minute is a set of clusters and
workloads that we can actually run
across each of these across each of
these each of these clusters so
okay so now that one connected and I'm
going to continue to the configuration
and I need to go and fetch a secret a
token here and I need to get this token
let me make sure I got the right token
so now I'm going to configure this
cluster and I need to move to
authenticate actually I need the
endpoint first so let me get the
endpoint got the endpoint I need to
continue to authenticate and I need the
token which I've got here and I'm going
to finish and I can now see my laptop
has registered cluster size of 1 4 CPUs
16 total total cores and I can now go
over to the workloads tab and I can see
my cluster cluster palace is running and
I have a gke Connect agent now I'm going
to deploy a workload locally using cube
Kittel so now I'm on my development
cluster here on the laptop I'm going to
deploy and expose that workload and I
can see that it's running and that's its
IP address port 9 8 7 6 and so I can go
to here and I can see every time i
refresh this I get a cute little cute
look at that an adjective and a an
animal now what's amazing is that if i
refresh my workloads tab on this I can
see the pet name workload this is
running in Google cloud and I've got a
workload here running ok that's pretty
amazing now probably the top question
that I've gotten over the last we've
gotten over the last two days is can I
run GK on Prem on bare metal can I run
GK on Prem in Amazon even though it's
called GK on Prem and so that question
has come up over and over and over again
so what I'm about to show you is
certainly not a product plan but I'm
about to show you that the GK connect
technology yes it works just the same
across the board so I've got an instance
running here in Amazon and if a cubic
it'll get all I can see I've got some
clothes running here inside of this
inside of here and if I go to my
clusters and I register an external
cluster and I call this the cluster AWS
simply for demo purposes and I go over
and I apply the secret siamo and the
cluster AWS Connect and I come back here
and voila we are now connected and if I
continue to the to this and I get my
local endpoint it's important to
understand this there is a local
endpoint this is not routable I have to
have the connection agent to get to that
local endpoint and I continue and I need
to get the token
and I've got this token it'll describe
and this token is unique per cluster so
I've got a copy of that each and every
time and now registered and it's going
to take a second for the cluster size in
the course to come up as it starts
exchanging information and we are
actually out of time but hopefully we
will get to see some workloads populate
here in just a second okay are we
strictly out of time or can I take a
question or two
we're strictly out of time I cannot take
a question or two all right I will be
just outside the room and I'm happy to
talk to anyone about more of this if
you'd like to see
[Music]